it's in movies in video games in fashion
and in music
p'malee all in a champagne genie no I
took a home and I enjoyed it Jamie rape
culture is all around us but what is it
rape culture is the normalization of
sexual violence against women you see it
in society's attitudes and institutions
it's the trivialization of rape that
makes people ignore it dope about it I
replaced for pepper spray with silly
string anyway that night she got raped
or think it only happens in dark alleys
a recent example in response to rape
charges brought against him singer Cee
Lo Green tweeted women who have really
been raped remember then deleted it
actually CeeLo raping someone while
they're unconscious is still rape as is
any sex without consent and
unfortunately it's far more common than
you might think
not finding it just give in to it I
don't know why I'm quoting a rapist in
the United States nearly 1 in 5 women
have reported being raped at some time
in their lives but the consequences of
rape culture are probably worse than we
know only 40 percent of rapes even get
reported only 10 percent ever lead to an
arrest and out of every 100 rapes only 3
rapists will ever spend a single day in
prison that leniency is a big part of
rape culture across u.s. college
campuses the story isn't too different
one in five women is sexually assaulted
again it often goes unpunished
Columbia University student anisole quux
who says she was raped in her dorm
kicked off this school year with a
powerful protest I will be carrying
matches with me everywhere I go for as
long as I attend the same school
campus sexual assault is so rampant that
the White House has even assembled a
task force to deal with it but that's
not all the government has on its hands
sexual assault in the military is even
more widespread one in three women is
assaulted by a fellow service member and
62% of women who reported their assaults
suffered retaliation
victim blaming is a big part of rape
culture that means faulting the girl for
what she wore what she drank and how she
acted instead of blaming the actual
rapist in 2012 in Steubenville Ohio two
high school football players raped a 16
year old girl who had passed out after
drinking too much but in this tight-knit
town that loves its football it was the
victim that received a lot of the blame
while the football players received
sympathy and though they were convicted
and served jail time one is already back
on the team what does that tell you
Greek culture means images of
objectification and violence against
women are so common for practically
desensitized to them so how can we build
a culture of respect and consent instead
subscribe on YouTube follow us on
Twitter and like us on Facebook